how's it going bros my dear welcome to
day life it's a whole new horror game
coming out 29th of April I'm really
looking forward to it it's been heck of
a long time since we did some horror
stuff I just been waiting for horror
games that I actually look forward to
playing this is definitely one of them
so without further ado let's check it
out what is that oh god not spiders Sara
focus is he they certainly have use that
in your hand to find your way there's
much to see much too where am I yeah
it's been some time now this place has
been waiting for your arrival
I love everything you can the memories
contained within these walls are waiting
to be found
sorry you watched succeed no I know this
place but how
who is Sarah Tuttle's
person 252 seems to experience of shadow
people my god damn it I hate shadow
people what the [ __ ] that's awesome
let's keep investigating I'm sure
nothing bad will happen at all
geez what the hell is this that's great
that's great can't wait to see what else
we'll find here a button must click it
no it's not about it well [ __ ] you can't
have everything in life all right what
do we got here this is something yes
thank you
the light will tell me what it look cool
more Margalo six more go six more glow
sticks a matura full you have too many
glows it you can never have too many
glow sticks that's what my dad always
said
oh [ __ ] who in the right mind would go
in there stop shaking my glowstick Sarah
okay well I guess we're going Oh patient
thirteen ten months old has readmitted
by her foster parents due to odd
frightening incident that occurred
shortly after she lies down oh Jesus
Christ
what is happening sir they can smell it
who can what okay sorry I told you not
to get ugly Titans now we're in this
mess together I hope you're happy
alright shadow people and oh god damn it
creepy wheelchairs and stuff hello oh
god I feel like I'm being watched I
don't like this at all hello I mean
don't help don't answer please we're
fine I have glow sex for everyone I
seriously have like a pack of fifty we
can have a rape party there's no need to
kill me because I'm a beautiful girl
they call me jab at huh
hi more clothes alright I don't want to
hurt anyone not just guys I hear
something oh [ __ ]
hello hello
hello patient salmon yeah ah okay
there's definitely something out there
what it's number two oh okay the flares
they're my protection stay the [ __ ] away
from me thank you
I feared upcoming closure for the
hospital with William to find a home for
yourself okay cool oh Jesus guy Oh Jeff
nook what was that what was that oh it's
a fan o-over fine it's all good it's all
good and that I have a flag you can [ __ ]
with me that's what the guy said and an
iPad you can't have my iPad it's my eye
back all right
the wind blow open here so I get to go
in here god damn this is creepy man oh
[ __ ]
all right I'm trying sure it's fine
[ __ ] shadow people man
I swear swear I swear I swear I hear
footsteps hello
oh Jesus guys don't do that Sarah oh you
just [ __ ] us ah thanks thanks oh oh no
no no I did oh okay it's a fight scene
six you're [ __ ] [ __ ] it's ridiculous
okay
just hug the wall stroke the firewalls
stroke the furry well okay anyone in
here
ah Jesus Christ I don't have any flares
which means if they come I am basically
done for whatever that day is whatever
doodlee dazzling that's been going on in
Spain
oh god what is that oh god please lose
your sanity here no this not anyone here
okay so just calm down okay
I come down sirens more badass than me
this is not okay okay Sarge you don't
know me at him
I think I saw that thing you would take
anybody the other day I don't know what
day it is very impatient it just stared
at me and then disappeared and shine my
light on a Bailey center with shadows
Adam saw something right that man just
Josh oh Jesus Christ that's nasty hello
shadow people
I love all kinds of people okay all
kinds of people it's okay with me all
kind people it's okay with me whether
you were shadow people or you're gay all
kind people are okay with me ah more
class that's what I need right now use
glow sticks to search deeper [ __ ]
hell man yeah keep shaking that glass I
know there's somebody here how do you
know that I don't know that and why
aren't you freaked the [ __ ] out okay
okay okay
I'm trapped that's okay that's okay
that's okay that's okay
all kinds of people are okay with me all
kinds of people are okay with me huh
oh Jesus Christ man can we make a run
run run runner
what are you doing they are coming
they're creeping up on me man and I
don't I'm not a big pile of creepers in
any game unless it's sand nothing okay
some people are okay with me what's
hotter
yeah answer I'm just a woman with an
iPad I'm just a walk away with an iPad
just a bum okay close in there oh I
can't open door Kenny Oh God
I hear them tapping or walking
oh Jesus Christ I'm not cut out cut out
for this [ __ ] okay okay let's the said
gel yes yes of cause not for [ __ ] sake
yeah you're just gonna what do I do with
this oh Jesus Christ
Oh [ __ ] fans man sorry no offense but
Jesus Christ man I don't like this okay
so he's logged
I need something to open that game which
means we're gonna go back into this
[ __ ] hell I don't want to I really
don't want it cuz I know he's out there
this is not okay man this is not [ __ ]
okay this game is [ __ ] me so hard
right now alright we're on the map have
we not gone here
it's amazing how I'll get what is this
Isis graffiti
wha what was that what was that Sarah
it's for the love of God just don't give
out don't know Sarah Sarah Sarah Sarah
Sarah hold me okay it's okay
what how this is a bureau ha ha ha ha ha
Jesus Christ
oh god they're scary
anybody there so you need to stop
talking kind of busy here
not dying oh god what is this
oh my [ __ ] tits all my text is went
to space they just went to [ __ ] space
oh god I can't even take a [ __ ] ah
oh god damn it what do i do what do I do
hey man we're chocolate okay
that's so [ __ ] jumpy right now okay
maybe there's some fun again bras you
need a she'll be a shelf an inventory
you can't ever have to take on sex
especially in a place like this well
that sounds great let's go in there
what the [ __ ] I don't even know what -
yeah I'd flying books and teddy bears
this is hello great that's great oh
Jesus Christ what what
it began with infection a black veil of
sickness and disease and despair
something sweet now that's a teddy bear
that's a [ __ ] teddy bear you're my
only friend so is he the one that brick
stood
Oh fuff ha NASA this [ __ ] ambience is
gonna kill me I have a teddy bear you
don't you don't you don't you just don't
[ __ ] up nobody he'll bet the salt
overnight oh come on
ah I don't know sorry what are you
thinking elaborate a little bit please
see you no no no no what
whoo-hoo Teddy don't freak me out please
thank you thank you I thought you were
too bro Teddy I thought you were a rope
please don't make me disappointed that'd
be great
running with Teddy that's right no shoes
here
Teddy sorry you're just freaking me out
when you say [ __ ] like that stop saying
weird [ __ ] okay all right I have to
Teddy please let me go in oh my god
Teddy what are you doing Teddy don't
fight it teddy
hey go you little [ __ ] aah oh god damn
it what is happening Oh goddamn it
oh I went through a wall okay okay okay
okay I can't it's saving gotta take a
little break in it sad I press I hope
you enjoyed this first minutes okay like
if you want part to live like its sky
come birthday
Rafi's Baha